from low budget mysteries from vicious
Blockbusters there's no bad Christopher
know the movie but which one Reigns
Supreme is the very best
as Nolan's debut feature following is
pretty good in its own right but more
than anything else it serves as a
testament to the types of movies that he
would go on to make flogging in at a
breezy 70 minutes it accomplishes a lot
in a tight little package true to the
title The Story kicks off with a man who
likes to follow people which leaves him
down a dark path The Narrative jumps
around between the future and the
present which is just one reason why
looking back is clearly a harbinger of
the great films that Nolan would deliver
in the years to come
Fresh Off The groundbreaking Memento
Nolan tried his hand at a suspenseful
crime Thriller with insomnia a remake of
a 1997 Norwegian film of the same name
Nolan uses the Alaskan setting to
provide some stunning imagery and
critics Praise Him result as an
intricately constructed Thriller and a
tour de force for a young director early
in his career as he would so often later
in the years to come the director also
benefited from a talented Marquis
including Al Pacino Hillary Swank and
Robin Williams the latter of whom
delivered one of the most chilling
performances of his career
Northern brought his trademark
intelligence to a period set mystery
with 2006 says The Prestige and in the
process he pulled off one of the most
memorable twists in modern Cinema the
story follows a pair of dawling
magicians played by Hugh Jackman and
Christian Bale as a battle to one-up
each other in 1890s London he won't
spoil the big reveal but we will say
that the deeper the film goes into these
magicians lives the more delightfully
deceptive the story gets critics lauded
the lead actor's performances as well as
Nolan's Deft execution of the big twist
and just in case you don't know in Magic
the prestige refers to the big reveal of
the illusion with that in mind let's
just say that this movie absolutely
lives up to its title
the final entry in Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy wasn't quite as strong as its
predecessors but it's still a fantastic
film in its own right Dolan brought the
story to a rousing conclusion with a
Massive Action that turned the entire
city of Gotham into a war zone under the
control of Bane played by Tom Hardy Bane
is a classic Comics villain who became
one of the most imposing superhero bad
guys ever brought to the big screen and
Hathaways Selena Kyle meanwhile offered
a rice spark and wit so the franchise
had previously been lacking although the
bat formula was arguably getting a bit
stale at this point no then still
managed to go out with the bang
the year 2020 was definitely a strange
one with the world locked down because
of the covid-19 pandemic movie theaters
suffered from the lack of an available
audience tenet was released at the
height of this uncertain time it was
meant to be the major Temple to get
everyone back to the movies but it
didn't quite work out that way as many
viewers waited for the home release
instead still it managed to gross about
360 million dollars worldwide on a 205
million dollar budget in terms of the
actual movie tenets is basically Nolan's
answer to Back to the Future but with a
spy Thriller narrative the ambitious
story follows a character played by John
David Washington known only as the
protagonist who learns how to manipulate
time to stop future events from
happening in typical Nolan Fashion the
film is like an onion that needs its
various layers peeled back to reveal
more about its message in this instance
it's Humanity's relationship with the
concept of time also since the director
isn't the biggest fan of CGI he actually
blew up a Boeing 747 airliner for one of
the action sequences ultimately 10 may
go down as one of Nolan's less
celebrated projects mostly because of
the bad timing of its release but that
should take nothing away from the film
itself as it's an Innovative effort that
makes for a perfect double feature with
Inception
Nolan walked a tyrope with Interstellar
telling a fairly grounded sci-fi story
Melody with a metaphysical message about
the Transcendent Power of Love it's a
wildly ambitious Saga spanning
Dimensions with the fate of the human
race at stake and Nolan worked hard to
get the signs right he pulled off
stunning Blockbuster spectacle while
also demonstrating how a black hole
affects the passage of time and
utilizing a wormhole to introduce some
positively stunning alien worlds despite
all that hard science Nolan never lost
touch with the story's heart at the
middle of it all is a mission to save
Humanity with poignant personal Stakes
as Matthew McConaughey's character
Joseph Cooper coaster the fact that
playing hero more likely cost him his
life with his daughter nice and easy Mr
Cooper
remember you know spring chicken anymore
the movie that first put Nolan on the
map Memento is also a textbook example
of what makes him such a great filmmaker
and the warish mystery and a gripping
Thriller with the most unreliable of
narrators it forces the audience to
piece together its Story one tiny detail
at a time while searching for Clues
across the tattooed covered skin of its
protagonist played by Guy Pierce the
fact that Nolan both wrote and directed
Memento proved Hollywood bigwigs that he
had the chops to take big ideas and turn
them into something audiences would Rave
about critics called it a masterful
execution of a high concept idea and one
of the most original films in years you
don't want the truth
you make up your own truth
the Batman franchise within shambles and
Nolan's pitch for a Back to Basics
approach set the series back on track
and reinvented the entire superhero
genre in the bargain Batman Begins to
nail the character's classic origin
story breathing new life into a familiar
tale with Christian Bale in the title
role and reinvigorating the character's
appeal for a new generation entertaining
is a coming adaptation or simply as a
straight-up action thriller grounded in
surprisingly relatable human drummer
Batman Begins but Bruce Wayne back on
top of the box office and it also proved
that Northern had the chops to help
Blockbusters that transcend simple
popcorn flick status
[Music]
Inception would have easily been a mess
in the hands of a lesser director but
with Nolan at the helm it's a
mind-bending masterpiece with an
All-Star cast led by Leonardo DiCaprio
This twisty Thriller is so ambitious
that it aims to bend reality to its will
and it actually pulls off that lofty
goal it's a heist film set in the
subconscious and Nolan handles a
dizzying layers of the story so
definitely that is basically impossible
not to be drawn in by the narrative even
as you're trying to get your bearings
haggled by critics as a smart flashy
visual effects Extravaganza it remains a
movie unlike any other and Nolan is
still one of the few directors with
enough clout to get a non-franchise
picture with this kind of scope through
the Hollywood System at all
once an idea has taken hold of the brain
it's almost impossible to eradicate an
idea that is fully formed fully
understood that sticks
there's certainly no shortage of war
movies in Hollywood history all World
War II movies in particular but Nolan
still managed to give that mid-20th
Century global conflict his own spin
with Dunkirk the story focuses on the
daring real-life evacuation of Allied
troops in the titular French city before
the area was overrun by Nazis instead of
relying on big action Nolan used a
narrow perspective to present the crisis
up close from the perspectives of the
soldiers awaiting rescue and the men
bravingly a certain death to save them a
talented Ensemble lined up for Dunkirk
including Kenneth Brana and Nolan
regulars like Killian Murphy and Tom
Hardy critics called the results
masterful and a fitting tribute to a
harrowing yet inspirational mission
Nolan's Batman flakes are some of the
best superhero movies captured on film
and the absolute Pinnacle is a second
installment 2008's The Dark Knight after
setting the stage with Batman Begins the
director really started filling in his
canvas with the sequel the late Heath
Ledger's mesmerizing Oscar winning
performance as a joker is arguably the
highlight of the entire franchise the
action is top-notch the story is Titan
focused and the visuals are stunning
Christian Bale had really settled into
the character at this point and his
command of the cowl made him a hero
nearly as compelling as his iconic foe
critics lord of the movie as infinitely
smart and stylish and the nearly
Universal Acclaim is Justified The Dark
Knight isn't just one of the best
superhero movies of the 21st century
it's one of the best movies period
see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the Curve it's pretty
hilarious how the opening of the
potentis Oppenheimer became entangled
with its bright pink release date
partner Bobby but there's no need to
understand that study in contrast to
realize that Nolan's 12th feature may
very well be his magnum opus the biopic
Stars Killian Murphy as J Robert
Oppenheimer who's often referred to as
the father of the atomic bomb it
explores the nature of the man and his
team's groundbreaking scientific
achievement while also presenting the
philosophical and moral size of the
equation as humanity is granted the
power to destroy itself in typical
Northern fashion the film features an
All-Star cast including the likes of
Emily Blunt Florence Pugh and Robert
Downey Jr he will turn in Sensational
and nuanced performances this is a
complex film about one of the most
harrowing times in modern history and
everyone treats it with a consideration
it deserves Nolan doesn't pull out the
Hollywood glass and turn Oppenheimer
into an unfortunate Mata or provide a
traditional happy ending that studio so
often demand instead he lists a
thought-provoking question ring long
after the credits roll namely Lee how
far are we from Total Annihilation from
the pristine technical execution to the
Deep thematic exploration Oppenheimer is
a singular cinematic achievement it's
not only Nolan's best it's also likely
to be remembered as one of the greatest
films of all time
[Music]
thank you